foreign
ERS sending hidden messages to children
that only your most conservative Uncle
can decipher and the director of Back to
the Future the ride
comes a sequel that ditches the low
stakes appeal of Ant-Man in favor of an
infinite Loop of Kang movies
so Jonathan Majors plays all of them too
late to change that in post huh Google
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania in a
world where the same effects team has to
balance this and wakanda forever at the
same time comes a theatrically released
collection of storyboards where every
actor looks copy pasted into their
scenes
reacts to absolutely nothing real
[Music]
and wanders around a stomach churning
world of British Brown pond water come
on
he's been 200 million dollars on this
and it still looks like gritty's
colonoscopy Scott Lang is a famous
author now or at least famous enough to
leave all his day one homies behind back
it up
now he just wants to be a good dad
because hopefully the third Cassie's the
charm Cassie Lang is the mcu's fifth
canonical child science genius your
daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement doing what any
girl her age would do in San Francisco
woke stuff you shrank a cop car what was
I supposed to do look the other way hope
has returned with nothing new to offer
besides her tactical Hobbit hair Janet
Van Dyne is back to vaguely hint at all
the quantum sex he had in the quantum
realm I had no idea I know it's
we'll talk later she
she never said anything
well I don't think I would have told my
kid either wild stuff I had knees oh my
God and Michael Douglas is never too
stoned to wander around and talk about
ants for a paycheck science
with ants
and science uh this just makes me
nostalgic for that Ant-Man one promo
truly the most honest trailer of them
all journey into the quantum realm and
join our heroes on a desperate search
for a reason to make more MCU movies as
we all trudge through a half-assed orb
Heist fetch Quest that's just an excuse
to set up the next big villain him you
left all of us
with him he's looking for you they are
talking about Kang right not from me and
not from him he is the future yeah we
met him in Loki you don't have to be coy
about the name oh
for him it's not a big reveal he told us
who he was he's in the cold open uh
whatever Jonathan major is dust off his
best Shakespeare in the park boys that's
what conquerors do as this once powerful
being who refuses to accept he's been
canceled
over and choose scenery like a guy who
knows that he's going away for a while
so he better stretch each line as long
as possible what are you going to do
and the time when along for the ride or
enough kooky aliens to let you know a
Rick and Morty guy wrote this one too
with new characters like Captain Obvious
everyone
is disgusting Bill Murray trying to be
the fun Cameo that Jeff Goldblum was but
Trends closer to another Ralph boner
boner and the nod ready for Prime Time
Modoc a floating joke with a grave
warning for illumination Studios do not
even think about making a live-action
Minions movie
so while spending time with the Ageless
Paul Rudd is always a treat settle in
for a universe that's gotten so big it's
starting to collapse under its own
weight that should have kept Ant-Man as
the refreshing after dinner man instead
of a dance floor salad to prop up the
next 30 of these dumb things ah can we
just skip to the new Fantastic Four I'd
rather watch Louise recap the rest of
phase five I'll see that's complicated
because when I first starring
small ride Hope Floats The Mask Stinger
Ant-Man original recipe mad woman
kangaroo shoes the mid Place Kirby
sneeze land lord krylar with musical
guest ants dad Punker henchman at my
house my house broccoli Rob
and Mr E from the band eels because his
real-life dad invented Multiverse Theory
said that's the most mind-blowing thing
in a 200 million dollar movie
the itty bitty witty committee
how many holes do you have yeah seven
holes
wait are you sure there's seven I think
that I Halls would count no did the math
and butter count as one for being
connected what about the separate peel
for girls uh you for making me do
whole math hey screen junkies now that
comic book movies are flopping in
theaters we did the actual math to find
out if box office bombs kill careers
click the box in the right to see if the
rock will ever work again in an all-new
episode of by the numbers
subscribe
if you need to spew spew into this
Whopper Whopper Whopper Whopper I am
Rodney motisa from the earl gray tribe
of the Congo